die amerikanische wahl ist gelaufen joe
biden hat sie gewonnen und wird der 46
präsident der vereinigten staaten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aber ist das ergebnis wirklich schon
endgültig donald trump erkennt es nicht
an
wie geht es jetzt also weiter bisher
sind es nur die medien die gesagt haben
dass joe biden gewonnen hat aber das ist
nichts ungewöhnliches in amerika denn es
gibt in dem land keinen bundeswahlleiter
vor dem 6 januar wenn der kongress zum
ersten mal das wahlergebnis bestätigt
gibt es kein offizielles endergebnis in
amerika
deshalb ist diese rolle immer den medien
zuge kommen und sie haben es sehr
vorsichtig gemacht dieses jahr aber sie
sind zu dem schluss gekommen es gibt
keine chance mehr dass donald trump in
den entscheidenden staaten joe biden
kleinen vorsprung noch einholen
israel will katar illegal with the
country to steal viel action from the
donald trump hat die niederlage nicht
eingestanden sondern behauptet sie gehe
auf millionenfachen betrug zurück die
klagen die die kampagne eingereicht hat
bisher wirken aber nicht so als ob es
irgendeine chance gäbe dass gerichte
tatsächlich aber tausende stimmen für
ungültig erklären könnten
vielleicht geht es dem präsidenten auch
nur darum sozusagen als gewinner der
herzen das weiße haus zu verlassen so
tun zu können als sein nicht alles mit
rechten dingen zugegangen dass er
wirklich noch einmal am ergebnis etwas
ändert das sagen ihm offenbar auch seine
berater von morgens bis abends das steht
nicht mehr zu erwarten
[Musik]
zunächst einmal muss jeder einzelne
bundesstaat die wahlergebnisse im
jeweiligen staat zertifizieren
das dauert ziemlich lange bis zum 8
dezember soll das sein und zum beispiel
kalifornien will sich sogar noch mehr
zeit nehmen
das sind also noch mehrere wochen in
denen die tram kampagne zweifel sehen
kann ob ich so kritiklos lehrwerkstätte
des schneider hudgens am 14
dezember erst takt dann das elektron
college dieses gremium der wahlleute
wobei die kommen gar nicht alle zusammen
auch das findet wieder nur in den 50
bundesstaaten getrennt statt dort
treffen sich die wahlleute
und sie müssen den kandidaten wählen der
die meisten stimmen in dem staat
bekommen hat wie bei jeder
präsidentenwahl gibt es da noch ein
bisschen aufregung könnte sein dass die
wahlleute am ende jemanden wählen den
die bürger gar nicht wollten
wie jedes mal ist das auch diesmal
unwahrscheinlich wir haben es schon vor
der wahl gesagt jetzt hängt ganz viel
davon ab was die republikaner tun
versprechen sie sich etwas davon an der
seite donald trumps das wahl ergebnis
anzufechten
im moment sieht es nicht danach aus
donald trump hat zwar noch einige
verbündete die wie er laut über
wahlbetrug schimpfen aber offenbar gibt
es einige mehr republikaner die sich
wünschen würden dass er endlich das
ergebnis anerkennt allerdings ist nach
der wahl vor der wahl und es gibt noch
ein ganz wichtiges datum in amerika
anfang januar nämlich eine stichwahl für
den senat in georgia
gleich zwei senatoren aus georgia müssen
gewählt werden kein kandidat weder
demokraten noch republikaner hat in der
ersten runde die nötigen 50 prozent
bekommen und es hängt davon ab ob die
republikaner ihre mehrheit im senat
verteidigen das ist für die republikaner
fast so wichtig wie die frage wer ins
weiße haus ziehen darf und wir können
uns vorstellen dass es jetzt noch
sozusagen einen riesen zweiten wahlkampf
nur im staat georgia gibt
und da können es die republikaner nicht
wirklich gebrauchen dass es jetzt einen
langen streit mit donald trump über das
wahlergebnis gibt
joe biden tut wenigstens so als lässt er
sich davon gar nicht ablenken er
bereitet sich jetzt auf die übernahme
der regierungsgeschäfte am 20 januar vor
so viel zeit hat trump auf jeden fall
noch das land zu regieren
und wahrscheinlich wird die korona krise
in dieser zeit sich noch weiter
zuspitzen denn auch amerika erlebt im
moment jeden tag neue höchstwerte bei
den infektionen und die krankenhäuser
fühlen sich joe biden hat ein team
zusammengestellt aus fachleuten die
nicht nur zu corona aber vor allem zu
corona jetzt schon pläne entwickeln
damit er loslegen kann
diese transition gehört dazu es ist
extra relativ viel zeit dafür eingeplant
im amerikanischen system aber noch ist
nicht ganz sicher ob das weiße haus
kooperiert die idee ist eigentlich dass
der wahlsieger sozusagen den
generalschlüssel zur regierung bekommt
dass seine leute jetzt in alle
ministerien gehen können und fragen
können was die prioritäten sind aber
donald trump sieht sich selber als
wahlsieger und könnte geneigt sein
beiden diesen zugang zu verwehren beiden
vorteil ist dass er acht jahre lang der
vizepräsident von barack obama war wie
man präsident ist wie das weisse haus
funktioniert wie die regierung
funktioniert all das muss ihm bestimmt
nicht donald trump beibringen
trotzdem hoffen seine leute dass es
leute in der tram regierung gibt die mit
ihnen kooperieren
ich erinnere mich noch gut wie es vor
vier jahren war als zwei tage nach der
wahl barack obama donald trump im weißen
haus empfangen hat für sehr viele
amerikaner die trump nicht gewählt
hatten war das ein schock dieses bild zu
sehen aber barack obama hat gesagt wir
sind ein team wir sind in einer
mannschaft wir sind team america und hat
versucht zuversicht zu verbreiten
mit solchen bildern ist dieses jahr wohl
nicht zu rechnen